I don't know if you've seen this clip if
you haven't you should should watch it
like four years ago I went on CNN and
said I only believed in two things
completely the first amendment in boobs
right live on the air they banned me I'm
not allowed on CNN now because you said
boobs because I said boobs straight up
straight it was my friend who banned him
by the way but I didn't know him at the
time so otherwise I would have stepped
in just because you said the word the
contest
it was the number one trending topic in
America uh she wanted me to apologize I
didn't do it the reason why I bring it
up is that was like four or five years
ago my uh oldest son last year
on the screen yeah there we go that's it
oh man
I believe in only two things completely
the First Amendment and boobs and so
once they made the decision that they
were not did you just say wow
it's related commentary
I just want to make sure I heard you
correctly as a woman anchoring the show
did you say what did you say you believe
in the First Amendment ends bwbs
you can't even say boobs two things that
have only never let me down in this
entire country
first amendment absolutist I believe so
you got canceled because of that oh they
tried I mean legitimately they tried to
get me fired off my radio show I mean I
owned out kicks so I mean that's one of
the benefits I think of owning your own
methods of distribution and I would say
to anybody who wants to get involved in
media
um one of the most important things is
you have to control I believe your
ability to make money in some way
because there's so much pressure out
there on media entities that as soon as
you get a little bit outside of the
acceptable bounds of discourse uh but
that clip that you guys watched I think
that was 2017-ish 18 whatever it was it
suddenly went viral on Tick Tock and so
every kid in my kids school very
interested never knew it existed got it
right because they're like eight or nine
years old when that happens yeah
suddenly every one of them had seen it
millions of people it was all positive
the kids loved it but that was an
audience that had never seen me so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]